this is a wonderful time to play video
games playstation 2 games are coming to
the playstation 4 twitter is a great
place to talk to your fellow gamers and
now those two worlds are colliding with
hashtag ps2 ps4 want to bring your
favorite ratchet and clank game to the
current generation tweeting the best way
to do it Playstations Dave thatch
started the hashtag and it's definitely
picking up steep using the hashtag
doesn't guarantee your game will make
the cut but it will at least bring it to
Sony's attention fans of ps2 is Haven
called the King don't have to despair
just yet the first batch of ps2 titles
debuted on the ps4 earlier this month
and Parappa the rapper 2 is available as
of today December 16th the king of
fighters 2000 is also on its way and
rumor has it that Max Payne may slip
into the roster as well remember this
isn't pure backwards compatibility you
will have to actually purchase the retro
games on your ps4 in any case it's a
great way to sink into the games we were
playing when hollaback girl was still on
the radio keep using that hashtag and
keep checking gamespot com for all the
games making their way to ps4